Você
sabia que sete em cada 10 pessoas que
tomam probiótico estão usando a CPRAD
problema que tem? Mesmo pagando caro, a
maioria está ingerindo produtos que
funcionam tão bem quanto tentar abrir a
porta de casa com a banana. Não importa
se o rótulo promete 50 bilhões de
bactérias, se a chave é errada, a
fechadura simplesmente não abre. Um
estudo publicado em 2024 no Journal of
Clinical Gastroenterology
analisou mais de 15.000 prescrições e
encontrou sempre o mesmo erro. As
pessoas escolhem probiótico pelo rótulo,
não pela cepa comprovada. Hoje eu vou te
mostrar exatamente qual cfa procurar
para constipação, diarreia, gases, cibo,
ansiedade, alergia respiratória, saúde
íntima e metabolismo. Você vai aprender
a ler os probióticos como médico
funcional. Antes disso, a regra do
sobrenome. Quando você lê lactobacilos
acidófilos, isso é apenas o nome e o
sobrenome. O que realmente define ação é
o terceiro nome. O código DDS1
299V,
HN019,
R0052.
É como comparar um chihuahua com
hotweiler, mesma espécie, comportamentos
completamente diferentes. Se o rótulo
não tem código, provavelmente não foi
usado em estudo clínico. Vamos começar
por constipação. Se você passa dias sem
evacuar, a cepa mais estudada é o bife
do bactérium Lactis HN019.
Um ensaio clínico de 2023 mostrou
redução próxima de 40% no tempo de
trânsito intestinal em 4 semanas. É uma
melhora fisiológica, aumentando o
butirato imotilidade natural. No rótulo,
busque exatamente HN019.
Para a diarreia e uso de antibióticos, o
raciocínio muda. Probióticos comuns não
resistem ao antibiótico. O que funciona
é o sacaromicis bard. Uma levedura que o
antibiótico não destrói. Metaanálises
mostram redução de cerca de 50% no risco
de diarreia associado a antibióticos.
Use desde o primeiro dia do antibiótico.
Procure sacaromices bard com
identificação CNCMI
745.
Agora, gases e estofamento em síndrome
intestino irritável, as cepas com melhor
evidência são lactobacilos plantar 299V
e lactobacilos acidófilos DDS1.
Essas cepas reduzem dor, distensão e
alternância de evacuações ao longo de 8
semanas. Já no CIBO, a lógica é outra. A
cepa mais estudada é bacilos coágulants,
um probiótico esporulado que resiste ao
ácido gástrico e age no intestino
delgado. Em sibo, evitar probióticos
genéricos com fibras fermentáveis é
essencial para não agravar os sintomas.
Paraa ansiedade leve existe o eixo
intestino cérebro. Uma revisão de 2024
destacou a combinação lactobacilos e
R0052
com bif do bactérium longo R0175.
Essa dupla reduz o cortisol, melhora a
resiliência ao stress e modula gaba. Seu
objetivo é efeito emocional ligado ao
intestino, procure R0052
e R0 175 no rótulo. Em alergia
respiratória e rinite, a cepa com melhor
evidência é Lactobacilos Paracazei LP3.
Um estudo com mais de 400 crianças
mostrou melhora comparável antistamínico
com o benefício sustentado mesmo após
parar o uso. O mecanismo envolve
modulação de respostas TH1 e TH2 e
redução de GE específica.
Para candidias e vaginos de repetição, a
combinação mais poderosa é o
lactobacilos Raminosos GR1 com
lactobacilos Reutere RC14.
Metanálises mostram redução próxima de
70% nas recorrências quando usadas com
via oral, porque essas cepas colonizam o
intestino e migram pro trato
geniturinário, restaurando o microbioma
protetor. Agora, o ponto que gera mais
dúvidas, probióticos e metabolismo. Não
existe probiótico que faça alguém
emagrecer sozinho. O que existe é
modulação metabólica. A bactéria mais
promissora é o aermância mocini.
Inclusive na forma posterizada, ela
melhora a sensibilidade insulina e
integridade da barreira intestinal.
Outra opção é Lactobacil Gere PR17,
associada à redução de gordura abdominal
quando combinada com boa alimentação.
Vamos falar agora sobre rótulos, porque
é aqui que a maioria é enganada. CFUS
não determinam qualidade. Um estudo de
2024 testou dezenas de produtos e mais
na metade tinha menos de 50% das
bactérias declaradas e quase 1/x trazia
cepas diferentes das indicadas. Procure
certificações independentes, testes de
estabilidade e marcas que declarem cepas
padronizadas. Encapsulamento também
importa. Cápsulas gastrorresistentes e
microencapsulamento
aumentam a sobrevida das bactérias. no
trajeto até o colo. Se o produto exige
refrigeração e está numa prateleira
quente, ele está morto. Probiótipo
sensível ao calor precisa ser armazenado
corretamente. Tá em mim. A maior parte
da cepa chega melhor ao colon quando
ingerida com estômago relativamente
vazio. Cerca de 30 minutos antes das
refeições é o ideal, a não ser que o
produto declare tecnologia intérica
robusta. Isso aumenta significativamente
a taxa de bactérias vivas que atingem o
intestino grosso. E lembre-se,
probióticos sem fibra é como tentar
plantar floresta em solo pobre.
Prebióticos são essenciais. Fibrasáveis
como aveia, banana verde, alho, cebola,
pargos e vegetais ricos em fibras
aumentam a eficácia dos probióticos. Um
estudo de 2024 mostrou amplificação
superior a 300% quando probióticos são
combinados a prebióticos adequados.
Sobre segurança, efeitos adversos
costumam ser leves, como pequenos gases
iniciais. Mais intervenções no
microbioma devem ser mais cautelosas em
pessoas imundodeprimidas, com catéter
central, por exemplo, ou válvula
cardíaca artificial. Fora esses grupos
especiais e perfil de segurança.
Excelente. Agora vamos ao resumo rápido
para fixar. Eu também vou deixar escrito
na tela. Constipação HN019,
diarreia ou antibiótico, sacaromis
bardino
irritável e gases 299 V e DDS1.
CBO bacilos coágulas.
Ansiedade leve R0052
e R0175.
Alergia LP33,
saúde íntima GR1 e RC14.
Metabolismo aquirmância e BNR17.
E sempre procure o sobrenome da cepa.
Sem código não há estudo clínico. A
lógica é simples. Não existe probiótico
perfeito. Existe probiótico certo pro
problema certo. E quando você acerta a
cepa, o resultado é incomparavelmente
superior ao probiótico genérico que
domina o mercado. Agora saia do vídeo se
você gosta superficial. Eu preciso
simplificar aqui por causa do YouTube e
das limitações regulamentares. Na
comunidade fechada não tem esse filtro.
Lá eu compartilho protocolos completos.
combinações precisas, fornecedores
confiáveis, interpretação avançada de
exames e casos clínicos que não posso
mostrar aqui. É acesso direto ao meu
cérebro médico. Você tem lives semanais,
PDFs exclusivos, grupo no WhatsApp,
integração com quem está realmente
comprometido. Se você quiser ir além,
tem o nível dois, comiações científicas
de 2 horas a cada 15 dias, desse secando
artigo por artigo e entrando os
bastidores que a indústria não quer que
você entenda. Seu nome aparece nos
vídeos, você se torna parte visível
dessa comunidade de elite. Poucos têm
essa coragem. A pergunta é: você está
entre eles? Agradecimentos especiais a
nossos membros queridos dos estudos
avançados da comunidade fechada do
YouTube. Nível dois, Dr. Ana Paulo
Rodrigues, José Fortunato Burtinho,
Fernando Machado, Sou Jucioli, Cristina
Carol, Romana Moraril, Estela Mares,
Eloterapias Integrativas, Luís Anselmo
Neves Antes da Doença. Eu agradeço de
coração pelo apoio prestado.